two weeks of waking up to the sound of
air strikes and gunfire Sudanese are
caught up in a battle that's been in the
making for a long time a political power
struggle rooted an ethnic and Regional
divisions further Complicated by the
fight for control over natural resources
such as minerals and oil at the center
of the conflict are two generals the
head of the army Abdel fatah al-burhan
and the commander of the rapid support
forces Muhammad hamdan degalo known as
hemeti
both men are known to African Union
fairly well
and this has been going on for quite
some year this is not a conflict that
has just you know sort of broken out so
I am optimistic that the levers that the
Au has together with igat is going to
yield some real result but it's not
going to be a straightforward thing
Sudan has more than 500 ethnic groups
and politics has long been dominated by
an Elites based in and around hartum
burhan has traditionally garnered
support from his fellow Sudanese Arabs
while hamidty has a significant base
among non-arab ethnic groups in Western
Sudan including dotford
this is partly because he's from a
non-arab tribe the Muhammad
both sides have tens of thousands of
Fighters foreign backers and vast
resources at their disposal the Army
controls most of the economy but the
paramilitary group oversees gold mining
areas the country is Africa's third
largest producer of the precious metal
and in 2021 about 90 tons of gold on the
global market came from Sudan it also
has deposits of copper iron chromium and
uranium as well as abundant arable land
which supports the agriculture-dependent
economy Sudan is located on the Nile
River vital for irrigation and
hydroelectric power generation Wars as
it shares with Egypt and Ethiopia it
borders another five countries nearly
all of which are mired in Conflict the
country has strategic ports on the Red
Sea the only points of export for around
000 barrels of oil a day most of it from
South Sudan the despite this the United
Nations classifies Sudan as a low-income
country
if this violence continues it could
spill over and affect Regional access to
water mineral exports and oil supplies
and then there's the unfolding
humanitarian crisis the fighting has
killed hundreds of people and injured
thousands there's a shortage of food and
fuel and hospitals are out of service
many countries have evacuated their
citizens and tens of thousands of people
have flet all of which is putting a
better future for Sudanese even further
Out Of Reach Alex beard Al Jazeera let's
ask